how's it go and everybody gets warned
and welcome back to my channel the
cosmic winter where we talk about all
things Marvel and everything relating to
the MCU it's sad to think right now that
if it wasn't for Kovan 19 we would have
already seen the Black Widow film and
let's face it we would have probably
already seen it a handful of times a
black would a movie is something that
fans have been waiting for since we saw
her enter the MCU for the very first
time and now years and years later we
are finally getting the movie but
unfortunately we're getting it after the
death of Natasha in Avengers endgame but
better late than never and now that the
film is almost coming out in November
the cast is beginning to do some
interviews about the film and in one of
these interviews it was revealed why
Natasha never got a funeral and Avengers
in game we got a funeral for Tony Stark
but all that we really got for Natasha
was a mourning scene in the middle of
the movie but now in a recent interview
Scarlett Johansson has expressed why
Natasha never got a funeral and Avengers
endgame and why she probably isn't going
to get one in the Black Widow film
either so we'll break down what Scarlett
Johansson said and we'll break down what
she said about finally getting closure
for Black Widow in the movie but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all things relating
to the MCU and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
Thanos with the Infinity Gauntlet a
Funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment about the video down
below so very recently Empire Magazine
had an interview with Kate Shortland the
director of the black widow film and
during this interview two major things
were revealed one is that we're going to
be getting a new Black Widow as most
expected and two is the reason why
Natasha didn't get a funeral as far as a
new Black Widow goes if you missed my
last video on this quickly here's what
they said Kevin Feige realised that the
audience would expect an origin story so
of course we went in the opposite
direction and we didn't know how great
Florence P would be we knew she would be
great but we didn't know how great
Scarlett is so gracious and she said oh
I'm handing her the baton so it's going
to propel another fimo storyline so we
are getting a new black widow in the
form of Florence Pugh who of course is a
black widow herself
trained in the Red Room alongside of
Natasha or so we think
and we are going to find out in this
film but here's where they addressed the
fact that Natasha didn't get a funeral
and it doesn't look like she's ever
going to director Kate Shortland said in
endgame the fans were upset that Natasha
did not have a funeral whereas scarlett
when I spoke to her about it said
Natasha wouldn't have wanted a funeral
Scarlett Johansson herself said she's
too private and anyway people don't
really know who she is so what we did in
this film was allowed the ending to be
the grief that the individuals felt
rather than a big public outpouring I
think that's a fitting ending for her so
according to Scarlett Johansson herself
who has been playing Black Widow for ten
years now since her first appearance an
Iron Man 2 back in 2000 Natasha wouldn't
have wanted a funeral and that's why she
didn't get one because let's face it
pretty much everybody at Tony Stark's
funeral knew and pretty much loved
natasha as well it wouldn't have been
hard to do some type of service for her
to give the Avengers a chance to mourn
and pay respect and the fans as well but
that is just not the black widow style
instead
apparently there's going to be some type
of scene where we grieve for Black Widow
in the Black Widow movie now we know
that she's not going to die because we
know when she dies which means that they
may show scenes after her death such as
maybe a memorial to her at the New
Avengers headquarters or something like
that maybe in a post-credits scene or
they're going to show a scene in the
movie that's going to be really touching
something like maybe at the end of the
film she'll talk about finally retiring
maybe settling down falling in love and
it may be adopting some children since
we know that she can't have kids and
seeing a scene like that is definitely
going to be heart-wrenching because of
course we know that she's going to die
and we're not going to actually get to
see her have that life but no matter
what it is the great news is that we are
going to get some type of closure
according to Scarlett Johansson herself
in the Black Widow film not a funeral
because Natasha wouldn't have wanted
that but some closure so let me know
what you think about this what do you
think about Natasha not getting a
funeral because she wouldn't have wanted
one and what do you think we're going to
see as far as this new grieving scene in
the Black Widow film let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up-to-date on all
things relating to the MCU for live
updates
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fall off